i want to bring in judge jeanine pierrot
co-host of the five host of the new fox
nation series who is hunter biden hello
to you good morning who is hunter budd
you know what he's an enigma he is both
an open book as well as a puzzle but i
have to tell you you know that segment
that you just played is indicative of
how the government is slow walking
everything that they're doing with
hunter biden we already know that the
state department based on our experience
with hillary clinton trying to get
records and freedom of information from
the state department is always drag its
feed almost as though it's an
independent you know segment of the
government a unit and so for them to say
we're going to take two years and we'll
give you this stuff i.e let's get past
the midterms when the statute requires
20 days do it and they're not doing it
they're not worried about it but the the
whole issue now we're talking about
romania now you know we've heard about
ukraine you've heard about russia china
china 31 million dollars to the biden
family from china all connected to
chinese intelligence and many the ccp
but now what we've got is what's going
on in romania so we've got this tycoon
who's convicted of corruption he hires
louis free louis free gives joe biden's
grandchildren a hundred thousand dollars
now you want to say
why would you give someone a hundred
thousand dollars and made sure that it
was on record for future work
why give a hundred thousand dollars if
you're seeking to get money from an
employer did you already get money and
are you taking some of that money and
funneling it through a trust fund or is
this an agreement where you know you
expect to get huge amounts of money you
don't want to pay for it so you or you
don't want to identify it so you give it
to them this is dirt it's very dirty but
everything that hunter biden did is
dirty doj has been investigating him
since 2018 tax probe since 2020. now
we've got the new york times going after
him everything this guy did and in this
documentary that i that i host
you see a man whose life was tragic in
the beginning his mother and his i
believe his his brother sister died when
he was two his father just been elected
to uh congress and he grew up being
raised by his grandmother but when his
father became vice president hunter
biden learned how to parlay that father
and and he leveraged him for all kinds
of money and then we hear about him
using that money to pay the the biden
family's bills but when he went into the
addiction of alcohol and crack cocaine
he got involved with all kinds of dirty
characters and at one point in the
laptop that we all know was discovered
in 2019 or dropped off at a a at a
repair shop he says he worries that the
russians have a copy of what have one of
his laptops that have some of his porn
stuff on it and that they could use it
to blackmail him he's saying this on his
own computer and in addition to this
what we have is his debauchery is just
horrible he's sleeping with his brother
and his wife and then he we now know
that he was doing drugs with her that he
was that he was filming all kinds of
debauchery i mean disgusting stuff uh he
is a disgusting human being and anyone
else would be in jail without a doubt
well
you can watch it now who is hunter biden
available on fox nation now i'll see you
tonight on the five i'll be there hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now